when you were talking about intelligence
you mentioned multipartite quantum
entanglement so high level question
first is what do you think is
intelligence when you think about
quantum mechanical systems and You
observe some kind of computation
happening in
them what do you
think is intelligent about the kind of
computation the universe is able to do a
small small inkling of which is the kind
of computation the human brain is able
to do
I I would say like intelligence and
computation aren't quite the same thing
I think that the universe is very much
you know doing a a Quantum computation
if you had access to all the degrees of
freedom you could and a very very very
large quantum computer with many many
many cubits uh let's say a few cubits
per uh plank volume right um which is
more or less the pixels we have uh then
you you'd be able to simulate the whole
universe right uh on a on a sufficiently
large quantum computer assuming you're
looking at a finite volume of course of
the Universe
um I think that at least to me
intelligence is the you know I go back
to cybernetics right the ability to
perceive predict and control our world
but really it's nowadays it seems like a
lot of intelligence
um we use is more about compression
right it's about um it's about
operationalizing information Theory
right in information Theory you have the
notion of entropy of a distribution or a
system and entropy tells you that you
need this many bits uh to encode this
distribution or this subsystem if you
had the most optimal code and AI at
least the way we you we do it today for
llms and for Quantum uh is is very
much Trying to minimize uh relative
entropy between our models of the world
and the world distributions from the
world and so we're learning we're
searching over the space of computations
to process the world to find that
compressed representation
that has distilled all the variance and
noise and entropy right um and
originally I I came to Quantum machine
learning from the study of black holes
because the entropy of black holes is
very interesting in a sense they're
physically the most dense objects in the
universe you can't pack more information
spatially any more densely than in black
hole
and so I was wondering how do black
holes actually encode information what
is their compression code and so that
got me into the space of algorithms to
search over space of quantum uh codes um
and uh it got me actually into also how
do you acquire Quantum information the
from the world right so something I've
worked on uh this is public now is
quantum analog digital conversion so how
do you capture information from The Real
World in superposition and not destroy
the superp position but digitize for a
quantum mechanical
computer uh information from The Real
World um and so if you have an ability
to capture Quantum information and
search over learned representations of
it now you can learn compressed
representations that may have some
useful information in there latent
representation right um and I think that
many of the problems facing our
civilization are actually Beyond this
this complexity barrier right I mean the
greenhouse effect is a quantum
mechanical effect right chemistry is
quantum
mechanical um you know Nuclear Physics
is quantum mechanical a lot of biology
and and and and protein folding and so
on is affected by quantum mechanics and
so unlocking an ability to augment human
intellect with quantum mechanical
computers and quantum mechanical AI
seemed to me like a fundamental
capability for civilization that we we
needed to develop um so I spent several
years doing that um but over time I kind
of grew weary of the the timelines that
we starting to look like nuclear fusion
so one highle question I can ask is
Maybe by way of definition by way of
explanation what is a quantum computer
and what is uh Quantum machine
learning so a quantum computer really is
a quantum mechanical system over which
we have sufficient control and it can
maintain its quantum mechanical State
and quantum mechanics is how nature
behaves at the very small scales
when things are very small or very cold
and it's actually more fundamental than
probability Theory so we're used to
things being this or
that uh but we're not used to thinking
in superpositions because uh while our
brains can't uh can't do that so we we
have to translate the quantum mechanical
world to say linear algebra to
grocket unfortunately that translation
is exponentially inefficient on average
you have to represent things with very
large matrices but really you can make a
quantum computer out of many things
right and we've seen all sorts of
players you know from neutral atoms
trapped ions super conducting metal um
photons at different frequencies I think
you can make a quantum computer out of
many things but to to me the thing that
was really
interesting was both Quantum machine
learning was about understand the
quantum mechanical world with quantum
computers so embedding the physical
world into AI representations and
quantum computer engineering was
embedding AI
algorithms into the physical world so
this bidirectionality of embedding
physical world into ai ai into the
physical world the symbiosis between
physics and AI really that's the sort of
core
of my quest really uh even to this day
after Quantum Computing it's still in
this sort of um journey to merge really
physics and AI fundamentally so Quantum
machine learning is a way to do machine
learning
on a uh representation of nature that is
you know stays true to the quantum
mechanical aspect of nature yeah it's
learning quantum mechanical
representations that would be Quantum
deep learning
um alternatively you can try to do
classical machine learning on a quantum
computer I wouldn't advise it because um
you may have some speedups but very
often the speedups come with huge costs
using a quantum computer is very
expensive why is that because you assume
the computer is operating at zero
temperature which no physical system in
the universe can achieve that
temperature so what you have to do is
what I've been mentioning this quantum
correction process which is really an
algorithmic fridge right it's trying to
pump entropy out of the system trying to
get it closer to zero temperature and
when you do the calculations of how many
resources it would take to say do deep
learning on a quantum computer classical
deep
learning uh it's there's just such a
huge overhead it's not worth it it's
like thinking about shipping something
across a city using a rocket and going
to orbit and back it doesn't make sense
just use
uh and you know delivery truck right
what kind of stuff can you figure out
can you predict can you understand with
Quantum deep learning that you can't
with deep learning so incorporating
quantum mechanical systems into the into
the learning process I think that's a
great question I mean fundamentally it's
any system that has
sufficient uh quantum mechanical uh
correlations that are very hard to
capture for classical representations
then there should be an advantage for a
quantum mechanical representation over a
purely classical one the question is
which systems have sufficient
correlations that are very Quantum uh
but is also uh which systems are still
relevant to Industry that's a big
question you know people are leaning
towards chemistry uh Nuclear
Physics uh um I've worked on actually
processing inputs from Quantum sensors
right if you have a network of quantum
sensors they've captured a quantum
mechanical image of the world and how to
post-process that that becomes a sort of
quantum form of machine perception and
so for example uh fery laab has a
project exploring detecting dark matter
with these Quantum sensors and to me uh
that's in alignment with my quest to
understand the universe ever since I was
a child and so someday I hope that we
can have very large networks of quantum
sensors that help us um peer into the
earliest parts of the the universe right
for example the ligo is a Quantum sensor
right it's just a very large one um so
uh yeah I would say Quantum machine
perception uh simulations right grocking
Quantum simulations so similar to Alpha
fold right Alpha fold understood the
probability distribution over
configurations of proteins you can
understand Quantum distributions over
configurations of electrons uh more
efficiently with Quantum machine
learning you co-authored a paper titled
a universal training algorithm for
Quantum deep learning uh that involves
back prop with a Q very well done sir
very well done how does it work is it is
there some interesting aspects you can
just mention uh on how kind
of you know back propop and some of
these things we know for classical
machine learning transfer over to the
the quantum machine learning yeah that
was that was a that was a funky paper
that was one of my first papers in in
Quantum deep learning everybody was
saying oh I think deep learning is going
to be sped up by quantum computers and I
was like well the best way to predict
the future is to invent it so here's a
100 page paper have fun um
essentially you you know Quantum
Computing is usually you embed uh
reversible operations into a Quantum
computation and so the trick there was
to do a feed forward operation and do
what we call a phase kick but really
it's just a force kick you just kick the
system uh with a certain force that is
you know proportional to your loss
function that you you wish to optimize
and then by performing uncomp
computation you start with a
superpositions over a superposition over
parameters right which is pretty funky
now you're not just you don't have just
a point for parameters you have a superp
position
over many potential parameters right and
our goal is is using face kicks somehow
right to adjust parameters because phase
kicks
emulate uh having uh the parameter space
be like a a particle in N dimensions and
you're trying to get the shringer
equation shringer Dynamics in the Lost
landscape of the neural network right
and so you do an algorithm to induce the
space kick which you know involves a
feed forward a kick and then when you
uncomp compute the feed forward then all
the errors and these phase kicks and
these forces back propagate and hit each
one of the parameters throughout the
layers and if you alternate this with an
emulation of kinetic energy then it's
kind of like a particle moving in N
dimensions a Quantum particle um and the
advantage in principle would be that it
can tunnel through the
landscape um and find new Optima that
would have been difficult for stochastic
optimizers um but again this kind of a
theoretical thing and in practice uh
with at least the current architectures
for quantum computers that we have
planned uh you know such algorithms
would be extremely expensive to run so
maybe this is a good place to ask the
difference between the different fields
that you've had a tow in so mathematics
physics PHS
engineering and also you know
entrepreneurship like the different
layers of the stack I think a lot of the
stuff you're talking about here is a
little bit on the math side maybe
physics almost working in theory what's
the differen between math physics
engineering and uh you know make making
a product for Quantum Computing for
Quantum machine learning yeah I mean you
know some of the original team uh for
the tensorflow quantum project which we
started you know in school at University
of water uh there was myself uh you know
initially I was a a physicist apply
matician mathematician we had a computer
scientist uh we had mechanical engineer
and then we had a physicist that was
experimental primarily and
so putting together teams that are very
cross-disciplinary and figuring out how
to communicate and and share knowledge
is really the key to doing this sort of
indis interdisciplinary uh engineering
work
um I mean there is there is a big uh
difference you know in mathematics you
can explore mathematics for mathematics
sake in physics you're applying
mathematics to understand uh the world
around us uh and in engineer you're
trying to you're trying to hack the
world right you're trying to find how to
apply the physics that I know my
knowledge of the world to to to do
things well in Quantum Computing in
particular I think there's a just a lot
of limits to engineering it just seems
to be extremely hard yeah so there's a
lot of value to be uh
exploring Quantum Computing Quantum
machine learning in the theory in with
with with with
math so I guess one question is why is
it so hard to build a quantum computer
what are uh what's your view of
timelines in bringing these ideas to
life right I I think that um you know an
overall theme of my company is uh that
we have folks that are uh you know
there's a sort of Exodus from Quantum
Computing and we're going to broader
physics Bas dii that is not Quantum so
that gives you a hint and um so we
should say the name of your company is
xtropicalovex temperature Subspace of
information and the way to do that is by
encoding information you encode a code
within a code within a code within a
code and so there's a lot of redundancy
needed to do this error correction But
ultimately it's a sort of um algorithmic
refrigerator really it's just pumping
out entropy out of the S the subsystem
that is virtual and and delocalized that
represents your quote unquote logical
cubits aka the the payload Quantum bits
in which you actually want to uh do run
your quantum mechanical program it's
very difficult because in order to scale
up your quantum computer you need each
component to be of sufficient quality
for it to be worth it because if you try
to do this error correction this Quantum
error correction process in each Quantum
bit and your control over them is if
it's insufficient
um uh it's not worth scaling up you're
actually adding more errors than you
remove and so there's this notion of a
threshold where if your Quantum bits are
of sufficient quality in terms of your
control over them it's actually worth
scaling up and actually in recent years
people have been crossing the threshold
and it's starting to be worth it and so
it's just a very long slog of
engineering But ultimately it's really
crazy to me how much Exquisite level of
control we have over these systems it's
actually
quite crazy uh and we're people are
crossing you know they're achieving
Milestones it's just you know in general
the media always gets ahead right of
where the technology is there's a bit
too much hype it's good for fundraising
but sometimes you know it causes Winters
right it's the hype cycle I'm bullish on
Quantum Computing on a 105 year time
scale uh personally but I think there's
other quests that can be done
uh in the meantime I think it's in good
hands right
now